I'm
[Music]
[Music]
touched up on it and that was in episode
196 folks welcome we are live
uh with a special guest somebody I spent
time with in uh UK I think three years
ago four years ago Katie Hopkins it's
good to have you on thank you very much
it's good to be here yeah so let me tell
you the story what happened when I was
in UK she's known Katie your reputation
is is just phenomenal friendly you know
she's a big fan of fat tax she believes
there's no way in the world if I take
care of my health and I'm on a flight
and I'm a good you know 120 pounds and I
have to pay for extra luggage but you're
300 pounds we should pay for that
additional 180 pounds you're putting on
the plane line like Common Sense type of
stuff she believes in and uh she's a
professional talking smack like before
we we even got started Vinnie got a
mouthful from her
control over the mic but but when we
were when I was in UK I lost my wallet
and I left the wallet in the cab you
called around until we found the cap
until we found a wallet that's what she
did which was awesome and it was uh she
sees it I was at a good song I was just
looking there that's my so that's sort
of my LGBT haircut
that freaked everybody out so Americans
were always like well hold on she's got
short hair she must be a lesbian and
that's kind of my prison break out there
hanging out too much with Mobsters
your Rogers to be clear you are not LGBT
no I'm not I mean I mean I could because
as you get older you just have to sort
of widen your opportunity so you know
take what you can get it's open for the
idea I'm opening to that yeah but no I
was never a lesbian in this but I just
always had to make it clear I'd had some
head some surgery on my brain and um so
I had short hair but it was terrifying
for conservative audiences everywhere
yeah not a lesbian no but then when you
play
so let me tell you we got a surprise
guys we got a lot of topics to go
through obviously the timing could have
been better for you to be here and Liz
trust resigns after 44 days we'll get
into that uh we we got uh we'll talk
about what's happening with the you know
power bills you know what's going on in
the UK with the prices uh the economy
there and then at the same time we have
a two two special guests here today let
me tell you who's gonna be on zooming in
one of them is going to be are you
familiar with Phoebe plumber and Anna
Holland do you know who they are no so
they are the ones that are part part of
the the just oil activists they went and
they threw soup or all over Van Gogh's
sunflower painting they can they're join
us today they're going to explain why
they glued their hands against the wall
and and they have to explain it and we
want to find out why they're on okay so
it's going to be for sure
Katie they agreed to be on that's the
part so that's the fun part second thing
can we just address yeah no they don't
know oh my God no so what is that hook
on your face hopefully they stay
hopefully they stay they agreed to be on
today so hopefully they stay we're we're
going to be very we're hoping they stay
and then at the same time we have
Matthew bunon which will join us at
around 10 15. he is a professor of the
practice of energy National Security
foreign policy this is what he did he's
a current professor at Harvard
and uh let me see this here uh is an
American nuclear an energy policy
analyst currently a professor at
practice at Harvard Kennedy School
Harvard University he's a co-principal
investigator of the Belfor Center
project on management of Adam his father
George Bunn was a leading figure in the
field of Arms Control who helped draft
and negotiate the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty in of 1968
limiting the spread of nuclear weapons
worldwide and here's what he recently
said he said it's a very serious
situation President Biden is right this
is the worst danger of nuclear weapons
being used since Cuban Missile Crisis
and uh we'll see what he has to say
about it could be potentially go into a
nuclear war I don't know I mean we'll
ask him some questions sorry but he
sounds like the sort of guy I wouldn't
want to sit next to at a wedding well
and that's why he's on Zoom though so
we're making it we're accommodating for
everybody he's got the off button handy
yeah so you know first of all just it's
good to have you on it's good to have
you here we got a lot of topics to go
through I want to hear your thoughts on
your favorite President Biden to see how
he's doing so you can kind of [ __ ] some
light on him and then maybe we'll talk a
little bit Meghan Markle and we'll talk
about again people you like is what the
focus is today right yeah you've really
lined up something special I really have
I just wanted to get the best out of you
today I realized sex I got on a long car
Journey with vegans I just this is not
something I do yeah okay so Katie for
people that don't know you can you tell
them a little bit about your background
for people that don't know yes um and
which is most people I'm sure
um I am a former British Army
intelligence officer and I went through
the Royal Military Academy sound test
and signed up to fight for my country
for 35 years I had to be medically
discharged later with epilepsy hence the
lesbian haircut in our earlier reference
point because I was then cured of my
seizures and so now I bring my fight to
the road I threw myself on the road
about two months ago to fight with you
for your midterms and have been rallying
the red it in swing States for the last
two months moving every other day I'm
known for being outspoken I don't ask to
be liked but more importantly I don't
ask for people to agree with me this is
what I think I'm not asking you to think
the same and I've been called many names
because of my work of course one of them
sounds like which but begins with B so
I'm known as the biggest bewitch in
Britain and I'm the most banned woman on
the planet as well I am banned from
normal things like Twitter or PayPal or
my own bank account I'm also banned from
all British and U.S media apart from you
guys who are Independents and banned
from the entire country of South Africa
for highlighting the slaughter of white
Farmers by the ANC band me and I've just
been banned and deported from Australia
for speaking apps against the tyranny of
lockdown locking down to an island of
people for two years and I'm also banned
from a small place in Great Britain
called Wales but that's fine because
nobody wants to go to Wales because
everybody there is ginger or short and
that's who I am
great Intro by the way somebody needs to
write that and hand it over and say let
me introduce you to my next speaker
that's coming up here so well all I can
say is I'm far more interesting than
that dial art nuclear buffing that you
have coming along well we'll see we'll
see how it's interesting he's gonna be I
know what he's gonna say you know you
know maybe maybe he's pessimistic
optimistic who knows maybe you were
short of guest today I don't know well
then let's let's talk about you let's
talk about with you on that topic before
it comes up what do you think is going
to happen with Russia and Ukraine in
your opinion so it'll be so I'm a 180 to
this guy
um I think I'm a big believer in Putin I
love Russia I've been there on many
occasions uh Putin's a strong and
fantastic leader on the international
stage people seem to think ukrainians
are angels they are off their minds they
are mostly Nazis and the Russians are
doing a good job zielinski is a puppet
uh he was an actor before you may have
clips of him in rubber in high heels
maybe let's play them to the nuclear
buffing and he's being used as a puppet
and installed to create a situation
where that Biden gets to animate the new
sort of the industrial complex and uh
personally I think it's the biggest fast
we ever did see imagining Americans are
at all interested in Ukraine is Bonkers
most Americans couldn't find Ukraine on
a map respectfully and nor should they
have to so that's my point of view and
of course it's the opposite to CNN most
lefties and indeed people who live in my
Road in England who adopted Ukrainian
refugees because they're such good
people now if that's the case why why
are we being sold by the media of him
being a modern day Churchill him being a
modern day you know incredible leader
who shows up wearing regular khaki you
know military clothes and people have
bought into this house they're going out
to want to take pictures introduce
themselves you're my hero you're this
you're that why is why does the average
person fully disagree with you on your
position because
um mostly people aren't that intelligent
80 of people have to to be introduced to
themselves in the mirror and have to be
taught how to tie a shoelace also I
think um have to be taught how to use
velcro you know that sort of thing but
also look he's an actor it is perfect
for the job put him in a green t-shirt
always have him sitting down because
he's only five foot four and you know
that I don't agree with short people so
you don't get that sort of perspective
you go to have a photo with them and
you're like you realize you have to
kneel down this is not the good guy this
is not the savior of mankind that is
being dressed up to be you don't think
he is I it's not that I don't think he
is it's implausible that this is the
savior of anything so so when I was in
Iran and and the Shah that eventually
was in Exile they sold him the same way
to say this is not a good leader he's
not doing good for Iran he's a puppet to
the West right the phrase puppet to the
West has been used many times are you
saying he are you saying zelinski is it
because shot ended up not being a puppet
to the world yeah Sean ended up being a
person that actually did a lot more good
for that country ever since that
happened we saw what's going on with be
run so some people may say well you're
saying that because your position is
different but yes you know he's standing
up look their military is not the you
know Russia's losing so many people that
are leaving their country putting just
all of a sudden as 300 000 people that
are civilians to one or so who don't
want to serve it's the complete opposite
in Russia and then some say well you
know Putin currently has an 83 approval
rating from its people but who was
really polling so again going back and
forth and that's so tiring isn't it it's
so tiring to try and find the truth of
anything what we can say is we just get
a load of CNN reporters stood on the
skyline in Ukraine reporting on
absolutely nothing other than the fact
that stood on the skyline we have uh
Putin's people who still have him with a
massive popularity rating and this idea
that he's much weakened I think is a
myth and a fabrication either he's about
to launch nuclear Armageddon or he's
much weakened make your mind up which
one is it and this has always been a
power play for NATO Putin always had a
red line which he would not have NATO
NATO on his doorstep and that's what was
pushed via zelensky is to push NATO onto
his doorstep he was always very clear
this was a red line and he's acting
exactly in accordance with the way that
he said he would if NATO pushed the way
to to his doorstep do you think it's
likely that we go into a nuclear war
with this or no no I think it's 100
false I think it's very much like the
covid narrative people just are hungry
for fear and they're hungry to be told
what to do people enjoy a state of fear
because people are subservient people
aren't bold like they used to be people
want to be told what to do by an even
bigger government you know and my view
is the opposite to that we have to stand
up rise up uh be strong and and not back
down to any of this stuff not back down
to any of this stuff so okay so your
position is no we're not going to go
into a nuclear war it's going to be all
right it's not going to be crazy how do
you think this thing ends do you think
it ends with uh a Biden setting up a
peace treaty meeting for them to sit
down and figure out what to do with
different parts of the land do you think
it ends with Putin getting what he wants
to think it doesn't end for a long time
what do you think happens to this it
definitely doesn't have anything to do
with Biden and him negotiating anything
most popular prison of all time he
couldn't negotiate his own way of a
bathroom cubicle and we know that
without gel on hand to drag him out of
there it probably ends if if uh Reds win
the midterm terms we stopped fueling a
wall that America has no place in and
Putin takes over the bits of Ukraine
that he wants to take back and Ukraine
backs down but the only way that happens
is if America stops funding this
ridiculous war that Putin doesn't want
to be in so midterms
midterms why your interest in UK why
such interest in the midterms of U.S
because you are our hope as well you are
the light shining on the top of the hill
you are Our Hope in the UK we're already
lost we're already gone demographically
alone if you just disregard me if you
loathe me hate everything I am that's
fine but by 2030 Muslim births outnumber
birth to all other in my country we're
gone every city wait what did you just
are you serious
did you hear what she just said the fact
you can have a Google hold this up
birth Muslim person UK out at number any
and all other religion by 2030. wow oh
by 20 oh my God
wow wow
so they're not using condoms that's
basically Having Eight Kids each what
okay Muslim numbers to double by Twenty
every every British City
uh that mayor in every British City I
mean the big cities is Muslim why is
that though why is that you see the same
model here Minneapolis versus Minnesota
Minneapolis highly prevalent Muslim
population densely organized into
Collective housing situations when they
vote you'll only ever get Muslim
leadership there we will never have a
non-muslim mayor of London again it's
statistically impossible
you will never have a non-muslim mayor
ever again yeah of London London will
always go to a Muslim
because the population of London is now
densely packed Muslim population was
that strategic or did that accidentally
no no there's nothing accidental this is
strategic Power Player taking over of a
Nation so back to topic
hence the US is our hope as well in the
sense that this is where Freedom will
live and this is why I care about the
midterms and that's why I'm on the road
and your messaging on the road is what
what do you what are you hitting on on
the road the artist decided by ours I
mean the side that simply wants the best
for each other right so ours is the side
that wants everyone to be all right and
ours is the side that's been through a
lot locked down wiped out businesses
wiped out families split people up got
people Uninvited from weddings and that
they're synagogue and it destroyed
people's lives and people felt utterly
lost and then you had the installation
of Biden which I was there for in DC and
people have been wondering what on Earth
is happening to America people sit in
comfortable Studios like this but I've
just come up from downtown Atlanta and
white people are basically being hunted
and targeted in the streets it happened
in front of me I've seen white people
when they start to Scurry in downtown
places they Scurry like rats happened in
Minneapolis happens in downtown Atlanta
and that's the truth of these cities in
America and we can't let that happen
here it's already happened in my country
we can't have it happen here so so for
people in America who are maybe this
isn't in their top 10 concerns when they
wake up in the morning of course it's
not and they're just sitting there
saying well that's your problem that's
happening in the UK it'll never happen
to us so two questions I would want you
to address one who cares about this
issue why should we be afraid if they do
do this because some people are not
concerned about that and then the second
thing is what they're like the
likelihood of that happen in the states
um number one no I totally understand
most people have to try and get up
they've got to try and get their kids
out the door they've got to find someone
to help them find their car keys they've
got to try and get to work they can't
afford this that or the other and then
probably the dog ran off down the road
and started humping the neighbor's leg
like that's the reality of our everyday
it's a real issue it's a real issue I
I'm I am a regular mother I I do have
it's surprising I know but I like I have
a husband I I have three teenage
children like I have I have two dogs I
get the thing that's more important
but uh the reason it matters is because
people need hope and they need to
believe in something and people out
there
are battered right now people come up to
me in tears when I do talks and we have
time together and they're in a room with
people who just want them to be all
right people are in tears because they
are exhausted by being surrounded by
endless madness here in America and I
find that really hard people want to
believe in democracy they want to
believe in freedoms they want to believe
in things like medicine and for the last
couple of years many people feel those
things are falling apart
um but my message isn't a negative one
it is a really optimistic one I love our
side I love uh Americans because you
have freedom hardwired into your souls
and you have a second amendment that I
that I applaud and uh you know it's part
of that message is to that we keep going
our sight will always be uphill it's
funny I want to go to our sponsors but I
remember when you were on CNN uh and you
said Trump's gonna win it and you say
well folks like yourself who at the
Clinton News Network and the lady was
Shell Shocked
we're not the Clinton News Network we
let him is you're not talking about the
fact that in Florida Trump's coming up
et cetera Etc so you really call out a
lot of stuff and I want to go into some
of the issues that we have with UK as
well as the guests but let's first talk
about uh our sponsor today Aura so we we
decided to have or as uh one of our main
sponsors and we totally support what
they're doing couple different reasons
why is one uh the fastest growing crime
in America today's identity theft
there's a new victim every 14 seconds
last year over 50 billion dollars was
lost because of identity theft for the
first time in the history uh in U.S
theft from cyber crime in the U.S has
exceeded robbery home robbery and this
hasn't happened ever this is the first
time that this is taking place I'm in
the financial industry the insurance
industry every meeting I have with
insurance companies all they want to
talk about is cyber security every year
for the last six years are cyber
security insurance that we spend has
increased every year to protect
ourselves from clients so this happens
in business this happens in personal and
so what Aura does is it's an identity
theft fraud monitoring a VPN password
management and anti-virus software all
combined into one easy to use app you
may have one of those tools but not have
on not having all of them is the is like
locking the front door or leaving the
back door wide open there's there's a
test you can take on there to check on
your password one of our guys Aaron I
tell the story every time one of our
guys Aaron went on there 44 43 of his
passwords was found in the dark web just
by this easy
test yet he can do that can find that
for yourself so I highly recommend you
guys take advantage of this uh protect
you and yourself and your family from
America's fastest growing crime try Aura
free for two weeks and see if any of
your or your family's personal
information has been compromised you can
start your 14-day free trial at aura.com
forward slash pbd once again Aura
aura.com forward slash pbd aura.com
forward slash PVD let's put the links
Below in the chat as well as in the
description for people to go find so
okay so you're in the US wanting to help
with midterms because you're you think
the last hope for everybody around the
world is America and you said you fully
support Second Amendment yes you fully
support all that stuff how different is
freedom of speech in America second
amendment in America than it is in UK so
we kind of get you can get some Optics
yeah it's wild so I was in the back for
Uber yesterday and this lovely lady was
driving and I said something about
um difference in driving in the UK us so
it's different because you guys could
have a weapon in your car and people
kind of have some respect for that where
I live we're not allowed weapons we
don't have a second amendment we're not
allowed to be armed our police officers
are not armed on the streets of the UK
they don't carry weapons we have armed
response units did you know that police
officers in UK are not armed yes
they have whistles and batons right they
have a whistle a whistle that stops all
crime they got a baton yeah yeah they'll
beat some ass with yeah they've got
literally that that is literally what's
the logic behind that though
this weird and so I'm British but I'm
more American with the 2A thing right
this weird British idea that if you
don't have guns it makes you safer and
so when let's just say Jihadi comes up
and goes on a stabbing spree as they did
on Westminster Bridge he just stabbed
the police officer yeah and there's they
have just a whistle to blow
I've had a lot of whistles I've never
seen a whistle stop at McDonald's no but
they they only just don't have a whistle
they've got batons they've got they've
got other items they just don't have
guns what does that do with a knife
though or a car a matter to defend a
British police or their mentality I'm
letting you know they just have more
than a whistle well yeah but if the car
is coming at you at least a cop would be
able to shoot through the windshield
because I mean like she just mentioned
knives are are prevalent and a car bro
does a lot of them throw a baton Through
a Windshield unless your aim is amazing
and it loops around but no you need a
gun bro you need you need a gun yeah so
Brits do not understand they can
remember they do not understand guns
here's Morgan is totally anti-second
Amendment he sounds like a like he can
you he's he sounds like a smart guy how
is he anti-second Amendment not
believing him you know even cops or
people having guns it's the wildest
thing uh that's it's not the only thing
Piers Morgan has been disgusting about
he was disgusting about lockdown he was
pushing the vaccine passport he believed
people shouldn't even be allowed to go
anywhere near any form of travel if they
didn't have a vaccine passport he was
The Pusher of the whole lockdown stuff
that went on so don't even bring up
Piers Morgan so that was part one of
your questions was about Weapons Part
Two or something else yeah I'm like
freedom of speech so you're saying hey
you guys have you still have freedom of
this some people will see it's kind of
gradually gone away uh and you know some
things are being you know but still how
different is that in UK so for us we
have such a large web of
um hate speech laws so it effectively
truth becomes hate speech and therefore
if you speak the truth it's an
arrestable offense I've been arrested
for a column in a newspaper for example
we have people arrested for comments on
chat groups or if you make a comment on
a Facebook page that is not deemed as
appropriate that is hate speech police
officers turn up at your door and arrest
people and arguably you've got hints of
that here when you have the FBI turning
up at James O'Keefe's door for no
apparent reason other than he's on the
wrong team
um so certainly for us when I left the
UK a couple months ago the last thing I
did was a big stand-up night uh in a
theater with a guy that is just doing
similar to what I do that guy is now in
prison in the UK he was sentenced that
week when we got off stage he was
sentenced to five and a half years in
jail for speech for videos on YouTube
that were said to be stalking and
harassment of people basically doing
what we're just doing this he was just
bringing up different people Meghan
Markle but it was a lot of the BBC he
was going for a lot of their presenters
but for doing this he was he was it was
the first case of its kind and when you
get new law you know you're always in
trouble new law that said that that was
stalking online stalking and he's now
inside five and a half years and Katie
you feel it happening slowly but surely
here 100 uh videos are getting taken
down people there and I I feel it's
slowly happening and I have two
questions well number one what is their
goal when I say their goal like the
crime defunding the police you know the
Border inflation recession sending money
what is there because in this two years
it's gone completely down here downhill
when people talk about Trump I go love
them or hate him this would not be going
on I don't care who the hell you are who
you vote for if you can't at least admit
it's horrible right now and it's not
getting any better than that's exactly
and that's why my frustration with
journalists that just want to talk about
Herschel Walker's past history of
whateverness yeah I want to say come
here get my hand I'm going to walk you
through downtown where I was just in
Atlanta come see if people there really
care about Herschel Walker's background
or do you think they care about the fact
that I just watched a lady have a
cigarette snatched out of her face and
have her bag take I mean I got involved
in that and that that was returned but
the point is you know that is the
reality of on the road and things are
collapsing so fast here and it is
terrifying to watch uh but what I see is
a result of that having just spent three
weeks on the road in California is red
has never been as red like the red is
dug in it's not going anywhere and it's
there to fight and that's why I think
the midterms are going to be a massive
result for for the Reds and and last
question too okay and I it seems to me
and I'm I'm with you and I feel that
that passion but it's like to me it's
almost like the the red the the
Republicans they bark a lot you know
from from Lindsey Graham to Jim
Jefferies to um Jordan so I don't Rand
Paul
ohg getting them red-handed like you're
in trouble and nothing happens I it and
then what and I don't I hate sound like
a conspiracy theorist but when I say
they're on the same team one side's in
charge for a while the other side just
points nothing happens fouchies Rich
he's he got richer during the pandemic
nothing is going to happen none of them
are going to get held accountable so
it's almost I feel there is a portion of
the country that's kind of like like
vote for what for what it's not going to
change and if it does flip and it does
go red and then hopefully the Santa
somebody it'll change for a while but
then they're gonna come back at some
point aren't they yeah I see what you're
saying and I I totally get that sort of
sense of despondency but then I see how
people were so done with politicians and
waiting they were like right that's it
I'm getting involved in the school board
and then we had all the mothers turning
up at the school boards and then you
ended up with a young kid in Virginia
because it was only by saying we will
let parents have power in schools did he
get elected and he's now doing great
things yeah so the the bottom can kind
of work its way up but I I hear you on
that yep quick thought for you um we're
living in an attention economy eyeballs
are everything these days and kudos to
you because you're a brilliant talker
you know what you're saying you're a
shock jock like you're a Howard Stern S
type person and some of the things you
say are hyperbolic some of the things
you say are true not everything is
everything for you
um I'm wondering for you
what percentage are you saying just to
as a comedian to be hyperbolic and just
to kind of throw stuff out there and
what stuff is actually factual and true
so for instance I have a phone in my
hand this is a phone and you can Google
things with the phone so
um Voldemort zielinski a couple quick
points he's the same height as your boy
Putin they're both five seven he's not
five four Putin isn't exactly a giant
okay that's one number two I don't give
two shits about the Muslims in the UK
but a quick Google search will show you
that Muslims population will double by
2030 apparently and go from 6.3 percent
to 17 by 2050. this is Google Katie I
don't care thirdly I just Googled
pictures of UK police officers with guns
apparently they got a lot of [ __ ]
guns so my question to you is what
percentage of what you're saying is
hyperbolic getting eyeballs respect we
live in that kind of world Now versus
actually factual and true okay uh let's
go for from the start that you showing
me what a phone is and saying this is a
phone no that isn't really the way to
start an argument because that's to
assert that I'm stupid and don't know
what a phone is well you're assuming
we're stupid because we can't Google
things that you say as a factor would
you like me to answer what you just sure
you're going to talk over me we could do
either one I could go either way so but
go ahead this is all you
is it yeah go ahead so starting off on
that kind of tone I don't think is
necessary you then go to your phone and
say I can Google this like you've got
the biggest penis on the planet where
you might have the biggest penis on the
planet candy I don't know darling I've
got bigger balls than Caitlyn Jenner I I
actually believe you Katie I actually
believe you but go ahead you're so bad
at listening and then when you stop
talking you say go ahead for just a
moment in time you can Google anything
why don't you Google my name and see
what it says on Wikipedia because you'll
find out that I'm both a monster uh that
I'm bankrupted that I have no background
or backbone you'll find out that I've
bedded everybody in the UK many of those
things won't actually be true so just
because you Googled something that
doesn't really make you Elon Musk
darling does it just mean maybe you can
use one or two of your hands probably at
one side of your hand more than the
other it's had more practice you then
talk about zelenski's height as if
that's a fact because you read it and
that's a misinterpretation of itself
isn't it because just because you read
it on Google doesn't make it true my
flower pot does it and then you also
talk about the fact this old statistic
Muslims six percent walk with me my
flower walk with me through London
through Leicester through Birmingham
through Bradford and walk with me
through Minneapolis because you can call
it six percent if you make that
disparate in a population but in the
cities where they cluster together you
will find they have the majority it's
why they have the power it's why we have
a Muslim mayor it's why we have a Muslim
Housing Association it's why we have a
Muslim Police Association and it's why
we have Sharia law in most of our cities
and finally you managed to find a
picture of a police officer with a
weapon well done darling have a gold
star and do some more Googling maybe you
could watch some Cartoon Network while
we adults talk of course there are armed
response officers I said that as part of
my answer but most police officers on
the streets of the UK are not armed is
that okay for you yes my little flower
pot so here's the deal I again I let off
with the wait a minute hold on you've
managed wait wait this is totally
breaking weight you need to stop the
business stop value payment because
seriously what he's done he's Googled
police officers and they're holding
weapons which which must make him right
and me wrong I'm literally came here to
talk out my ass but look what he's done
everybody I think that deserves come on
number one thank you Tyler for Googling
it on your end well done
I appreciate again I'd let off with a
compliment that you're a good talker and
you get eyeballs congratulations you're
good at that part of the problem why you
probably pissed people off is you have
major masculine energy so respect to you
so I know you're saying you're married I
don't know about that I know you're
saying that you've got you're a family
woman
but Katie how can we trust Google Katie
I'm using your words against you
beautiful listen to pull your little
winky I will you can Google myself you
probably have a bigger dick
you're hyperbolic you get eyeballs
respect I'm also saying not everything
you spew out there is accurate
what was the compliment
that you get eyeballs and that you're a
good talker no I think if you're around
for 50 or so years in the media it would
be if you were spewing nonsense you'd be
caught out no you'd probably be canceled
everywhere and then where were you
canceled again I am literally canceled
from countries okay well is that a good
thing are you proud of that I am
actually yes I am well then kudos to you
Katie I'm proud you're doing what you
want to do in life I'm proud of being
deported from Australia for going over
there and calling out the tyranny of
lockdowns proud of standing up for those
people who had that done to them the
Australians needed you like they needed
Katie no and that's something I always
make friends are you even Australian
so I am not uh American I am not
Australian and I come over here because
I'm a respectful Foreigner and an
outsider that cares about your country
so you're a globalist no I'm not a
globalist well I'm just like if you go
and like I honestly come to United
States and and basically get involved in
politics or you go to Australia get
involved in politics I am not sure what
you're doing I'm not sure what you're
doing I'm asking you genuine questions
and see I can't help but feel you're
kind of angry but I don't know why maybe
I woke up on the wrong side of the bed
today maybe I was I had a British
girlfriend that you remind me of I don't
know however that's actually a true
story yeah
I know that's a true story
here's what I genuinely believe here's
what I generally believe I don't believe
you believe me I date a lot harder
chicks than you but here's what I
definitely believe you actually are a a
person that knows what they're doing
you're not an idiot you've been
confronted before you confront a lot of
people you've been you anti-liberalist
anti-multicultural anti-fat
anti-immigrant
anti-tattus sorry uh to inform you
Vinnie she doesn't like you you have
tattoos okay so listen Katie your Crimea
River okay there it is Katie she has a
tattoo on her bum Katie I've taken a lot
of heat before I can take it you can't
take heat Katie you take heat all the
time you give heat I just there's just a
lot of noise coming off you I stopped
lady I hear a lot of noise you just
sound a little more proper than me Katie
but we're all just talking noticing
you're making another thing of yourself
sweetie I'm enjoying you carry on
Patrick darling okay let me go to the
story here where Liz trust that's great
that was good it was very entertaining
audience is definitely loving it so Adam
good for you all right Liz truss resigns
and will become shortest serving PM in
British history uh she's resigned prime
minister just after 44 days from over
taken over Boris Johnson she will meet a
shortest serving PM in British history
and a statement outside A Downing Street
trust admitted she could not deliver her
mandate she said I came into office at a
time of great economic and international
instability families and businesses were
worried about how to pay their bills she
said she was elected with a mandate to
change this adding we delivered on
energy bills I recognize though given
her this situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party so one was she
somebody that most of the conservatives
were happy about did they want to
replace Boris with her and two her
reasoning for resigning is this a good
thing for UK or a bad thing I mean she
had to go so we were waiting for I guess
a day but we're kind of saying it was
down to the hour so you knew you knew
this was coming we knew something's
going so that once she came in with her
measures at the markets reacted really
badly to those measures so the pound
just plummeted we were at parity with
the dollar for the first time in modern
history
very weird it was crazy borrowing
weights went through the roof so
mortgages went through the roof in terms
of people who were looking to fix a
mortgage
um and so the markets basically decided
she was gone so she was already kind of
a dead woman walking
um she was brought in people preferred
Boris Johnson old money preferred Boris
Johnson so she we always knew she
wouldn't be around for long and it was
humiliating I don't enjoy yeah iceberg
lettuce in blonde wig at last list trust
I don't know if I really enjoy I know
you boys might enjoy that well I don't
know if I enjoy seeing it did you like
her did you actually like her no she's
robotic and weird I got you what I'm
what I really would love is if if
Britain had
um democracy that people could believe
in but honestly ordinary Brits a bit
like what we were talking about earlier
their daily concern at the minute is
they can't afford to heat their houses
they can't afford to buy stuff in the
store we now have something called heat
banks in the UK where old people are
supposed to go and heat themselves in
the day in public buildings because they
can't afford to heat their own homes I
mean it's a fairly dire situation I
suspect what we'll see well we're either
going to see Rishi sunac or we're going
to see Boris Johnson come back into play
and the latest rule that they've made up
is that 100 MPS whoever's going to run
has to have the support of 100 MPS so
it's going to be a very very fast
competition to see who's going to
replace lizard I mean this is not normal
though right 44 days 45 days the longest
was what 142 or 124 some number like
that that was in 1896 um 130 years ago
the race she was in to be prime minister
was longer than the time she spent as
prime minister
that's uh again so purely the the money
people didn't support it because the
economy was being felt under policies
and that's like we got to move on she
was gone got it so and and How likely is
it that a Boris is going to come back
because people are just kind of saying
let's just get him back in here he would
say if he was good he was is that kind
of what it's most likely gonna happen
great play going on there's a weird
dynamic Rishi sunak is what I think the
party would want I think it's what the
Marcus markets would want I think it's
what globalists would want you know they
love him because he's a Montecito boy
over in California with a green card and
the richest wife actually in England you
might want to Google that
um but I um think the people in the UK
loved Boris so if we then went to a
general election who could win still for
the conservative party not Rishi but
Boris could did you like him did you
like Boris I liked him right up until
the point he locked down my country
got him do we have an example by the way
do you remember like if I recall I
remember you know you can fact check me
on this I don't know why I remember him
saying uh herd immunity is the way to go
the only way to solve this and that's
kind of what he was pitching at exactly
he said that right yeah right until the
point that whoever got to him whatever
somebody's Pfizer somebody either money
I agree 100 but it's either money or
it's either they had something on him
because I remember everybody you looked
at from the past and you looked at like
even the interview without you years ago
where he says if somebody has this
should they give access no that's the
ultimate you know vaccine
so real quick how much of that do you
think had to do with Boris getting
coveted Boris got coveted bad he was
hospitalized he did that I think that
had a lot to do with it do you think
it's that or the fact that they had
blackmail he had a bit of a code for a
while and then he went and he was
allegedly in intensive care and we were
all specifically hurricane said he came
out of that thing and he turned on dime
and all of a sudden everything he said
before heard immunity masks don't work
yeah but here I am shaking hands with
people still because oh it's all a load
of old crap that's where he was and he
turned on a dime whatever they gave him
or whatever they had or what they have
on us probably an Epstein Island video
with like Hey listen bro we got this
video but you know what to it that is
the ultimate like that's what we don't
know yeah you know that's what we don't
know and it's a very very effective
method yeah because you're coming here
saying Hey listen man you're 60
something years old here's what we found
on you how do you want your legacy to
end up we're gonna go public with this
next week unless if you don't do that
dot oh my god do you not believe that
stuff happens I believe it does 100 that
happens and then they have you forever
because you have to say the course or
else that video or whatever they have on
you that person that's gonna come out
yeah is always going to be in your
Shadow well listen I mean it's credible
to Kim Kardashian she made it more than
listed 72 days I know Tyler just put
this yep uh 44 days versus 72 days is
that kind of is this a form of
recognition from you Tyler
here's what I would be curious about on
who's more likely to make a comeback Kim
or Netanyahu I would be very curious to
know which one of those two guys
or uh Boris yeah
well wouldn't I would love it to be BB
but Boris is already on his way back
from the Caribbean and doing his hair
he's getting ready yeah his hair just
changed and that means that means big
things are a foot when has he ever
changed I've never seen him fix his hair
I've never seen him yesterday he had his
hair slightly fit seriously slightly
well
Liz I know I know I know listen I'm not
defending
but he does I I guess intentionally do
this to be more of a comment because
he's an Oxford man very smart guy he's
not an idiot he plays sort of like the
bumbling fool he literally does like a
Chris Farley impression shakes up his
hair and he's like all right let's go be
British for a second exactly that's true
absolutely and that picture which we can
find with Google I'm supporting this now
I'm not having a go if you get Boris on
zip wire
um that's that to me is the what this
was with him when he was London mayor
and it's the epitome of how Boris wanted
to present himself right so he's up on
the zip wire look there oh God and then
the zip wire went wrong oh no
but in many ways it was all of our
favorite moment because it was London at
its best we were just about to have the
Olympic Games and he's stuck up there on
a bloody zip wire and just really quick
practice I wanna I wanna ask Katie just
okay I mean there's a lot happening with
you know maybe coming back Boris coming
back uh what's your name of resigning
what about the the Georgia Maloney
they consider her for every article that
I've read from BBC to everybody she's
just far right she's gonna start a war
it's all that but it's in a couple hours
I guess there's they're gonna the the
brittle the the it's gonna switch today
isn't it yes where they're gonna give
her power today how do you feel about
her I love her I love I love the fact
she's Italian I love the fact she's
called Maloney
like pizzas coming out for me I love the
fact that if you're an [ __ ] and
you're believing Google then you believe
she's far right whereas actually she's
so perfectly excellent in all her ways
and she's also backed up because of the
way the Italian voting system works she
has a salvini as well Matteo Salvage who
I've met who's the greatest man he's
gonna be like her sidekick oh wow
there's like a band of them so it's
perfect and also we have same in Sweden
Swedish Democrats so we're we're having
a good run let's run she's a the
difference between her and Alyssa or
Boris she seems like a real conservative
it's gonna stand up she doesn't she
seems Fearless I love her I mean so far
Adam you know said something he says
look we have no clue who this person is
this just came out of nowhere so far she
seems very Fearless uh very clear in her
messaging backbone yeah she's and if you
watch like her speeches in front of the
Italian times
it was it was like a speaker like it was
just I listened to every single I mean I
had to read it but it was passionate I I
it might be BS or whatever Adam I feel
you but I believe her Vinnie what Benny
did is Vinnie was so impressed that he
started looking if she has any daughters
because he has entry I love him but I
look Italian her name is Vinnie yeah hey
Milan the word on the street is you've
actually been hanging out with more
Italian people around town 100 100
Bertolucci a lot of these restaurants
because nobody believes when I say
Middle Eastern like yeah all right
witness protection let me give you the
next one UK energy bills to rise by 80
in October as a regulator announces hike
uh British energy regulator announced
Friday it will rise will raise its main
cap on consumer energy bills to an
average of 3 549 pounds 4197 US dollars
from 1971 last year so from 1971 to 35
for that's nearly that's 88 80 plus
percent uh as campaign groups think
tanks and politicians call on the
government to tackle a cost of living
crisis the price cap limits the standard
uh energy standard charge energy
suppliers can build domestic customers
for their combined electricity and gas
in England it covers around 24 million
households the 4.5 million households on
prepayment plans face an increase
from two thousand Seventeen dollars to
three thousand six hundred and eight
dollars that's real money yeah it's it's
wild so energy bills are now well beyond
the means of most people in the UK
people are turning off their energy at
source so at the point where it enters
their home people are living now with
candles people have head torches so they
don't turn the lights on and elderly
people are not gonna have their heating
on and we're at minus two degrees you
know we're not living in Florida yeah
that's right so I mean it's a shocking
State of Affairs and in a country that
is perpetually gray and cold not being
able to have light or heat I I don't
honestly know we will lose people this
winter and then all the while there's
just this circus going on at number 10
of who's going to be the next leader
well it's more who's going to survive
the next week without heating or light I
mean it is properly dark it's properly
dickensian yeah no listen if you got
money to use like ads who cares like
1800 bucks it's not a big deal but if
you're middle you income your low income
you're sitting there you're tired
that's a that's a big that's a big not
to pay to say it's going to go up that
much and and by the way what can cause
it to
um go back down like what what needs to
happen for this to go lower obviously
it's uh relationships with some of the
causes Russia some of the cause they're
saying is different places but what
needs to happen for this to go lower
yeah there's this I did it was being
kind of put up as this uh something the
bad guy you know we always want a bad
guy in a panto so we're using Russia
right we're using price hike and all
that blah blah blah blah but you know in
fact we only ever got five percent of
our gas from Putin in the first place so
that can't be responsible for an
eight-fold or five-fold increase
um gas um green taxes the green agenda
if you wipe that out that would be half
the bills gone you know so the green
kind of agenda that's being pushed is
one of the reasons we're paying for
everything so you know price
prohibitively because the taxation is
off the chart and then what we need to
do is push forwards with nuclear or push
forwards with new supplies or push
forward and reopen some of the coal or
whatever oil or whatever that we shut
down and clearly energy is not my field
but we need to increase Supply and pull
back on green taxation those are the
only two levers we would have
yeah I'd be uh I'd be curious to know
what the cause is like to go up that
high that sudden during the season we're
in so it wouldn't make sense for the
average person to say it has to be the
war between Russia it has to be the
north stream pipeline it has to be all
these things because it wasn't the case
two years ago and this wasn't happening
two years ago yeah but in fact they just
there was this price cap and they they
took the price cap off so the energy
companies can charge effectively what
they want and then the wrong time to do
it the profits of those uh you know oil
Giants have been huge yeah even the
Germans are being told to stop whining
where to sweaters and have candles and
flashlights ready in case of blackouts
this winter like this is a very you know
nice gentle warm you know
empathetical leadership message being
sent out the guy just go over two
sweaters it's gonna be all right
that's basically the same in our country
and they're warning Us of three hour you
know very much like California the
rolling blackout South Africa has the
same three-hour blackouts we're
expecting this winter
it's it's a it's amazing it's definitely
a wild uh wild uh situation that's going
on there with uh with this so okay now
let's go to U.S politics with U.S
politics that uh is going on here when
Biden got elected okay everybody was you
know oh my God it's going to be the end
of the you know it's going to be
horrible it's going to be this it's
going to be that
fast forward to where we are today is it
exactly what you expected it to be is it
worse is it not as bad as you expected
it to be
as a respectful Foreigner I'm bearing in
mind you've chased our British asses out
of this fine country twice before uh
someone told me it's three times but
um it's I think it's absolutely worse
than expected I I think we knew it would
be awful watching the installation of
him I was what one of 20 people gathered
around a side gate because nobody was in
DC because it was basically a a war zone
uh fabricated war zone and then you have
a man who it is so you know no one knows
what's going to come out of his mouth at
any given time he's just sort of seems
to have kind of some kind of Tourette's
or something he just squeals out about
inflation or whatever we don't know
what's going on then you look at the
border and the fact that we just have
illegals piling into your country we
have ridiculous rules in place like I
can't currently be here in this country
because unvaccinated people are still
not allowed in America as we speak you
have inflation at record rates you have
fuel prices that are at record highs I
I'm failing to see what's been good
about this Administration and in a
recession well mind you we're we're not
that bad because they changed the
definition in real time of a recession
we're sending literally how much is it
so far Tyler to Ukraine how many
billions three trillion um
I think well this just this past Ukraine
we had to Google I think Ukraine the
past year it's a 50 to 80 billion
dollars we're such a bad billion or
trillions this was Ukraine this was
March 10th so when you just said no
trillion we did not send 1.5 trillion
dollars to Ukraine wait can I just say
this was Googled but this this is not
right now there's a lot you can Google
that's accurate Katie but one thing
basically the issue you disagree with so
this isn't I'm just saying we did not
send 1.5 trillion well they just passed
the bill because I mean right now we're
at 80 billion yeah there's a big
difference between 1.5 trillion and 80
billion yeah I said trillions yeah
that's a bill that they just passed that
we are going through a 3.2 it's not
going to stop but my point being is 3.2
trillion to Ukraine guys no you have to
get an accurate number oh how what's
going to be accurate something you agree
with
let's just see a fact Katie I don't know
you just saw a headline you're sending
money to yeah so now we believe in
headlines yeah I I remember the number
being somewhere around 60 billion
dollars everything I've seen is 70 to 80
but I
um I mean I don't need to be a
mathematician you're saying 70 to 80
billion and we're talking about
trillions we know how numbers work here
guys is it billion or trillion which is
it's billions right now but what she
said from what I think what you're
saying is Katie they they passed a bill
in March that's saying they're gonna
give them up to 1.2 trillion dollars
it's not going to stop but but my going
back to my point is if we're such in bad
shape and everything's going downhill so
that's how do we have the goal to send
them so that was one of my points I
didn't ask earlier is what what is our
goal on on helping them so much what
what why are we so invested in this war
and mind you it was only a two-week
thing where I saw the Ukraine ribbons
and every website was Ukraine and then
keeping up the Kardashians came on and
people were like the hell Ukraine what's
happening with Kim's vagina because
that's what sold people's attention span
so that's why I was very cute it's true
like it's so terribly the same in the UK
so these people that had flags up for
our socialized Healthcare yeah for NHS
and then they took those down and put up
Ukraine Flags every week every week is
something different and then the people
who brought in Ukraine refugees realized
they didn't really like Ukraine people
and were trying to get them out yeah
it's pretty funny weird yeah no it's not
it's not up to 1.2 trillion Vinnie I
want to make sure we get that right okay
that 1.2 trillion 1.5 trillion dollars
under it was a portion going to Ukraine
portion going to pandemic portion going
to agencies I want to say we're on the
70 billion dollar number give or take to
Ukraine thus far 70 billion which is in
a recession we we have oh no one's
saying no one's real money and it's not
one and a half trillion dollars to uh uh
one and a half trillion we can buy
Ukraine we don't even say hey your hours
come over
health care and Social Security
and then a percentage of that a good not
the full 1.5 trillion kitties
that's not what he just said you added
there were no I'm saying there were
other parts of the bill I did what those
are like Social Security make it sound
like it's going to Americans it won't be
of the 1.5 trillion 80 billion went to
Ukraine okay so that means there's 1.425
80 billion go to Ukraine at a time when
Americans can't afford to put gas in
their cars he's a bit silly
I'm 100 zero money to anybody when
there's as a veteran to a veterans
that's a different conversation
we should spend any money to Ukraine I'm
still but they're on 3.2 but I
appreciate you you just went on 1.5
trillion to 3.2 trillion 3.2 trillion
was always going 1.5 is the bill that's
from from March correct yeah you're
saying I just want to be clear I'm not
being an [ __ ] you're saying that we
actually sent 3.2 trillion dollars to
Ukraine I believe that's where you're at
that's not where I'm at you're so I
believe that's where the number is at
that's what I would love a fact check
use a DuckDuckGo use a Google use a bing
I don't care I think that's a highly
inaccurate number there's no way we
spent
3.2 trillion dollars on Ukraine Kitty
the number the number 3.2 KD you may be
mixing it up and and I'm totally fine if
I'm wrong the 3.2 is how much we spend
in Afghanistan in 20 years that number
is three trillion dollars we spent 20
years in Afghanistan I think when it
comes down to Ukraine I do think it's 70
to 80 billion dollars it's maybe we can
get to a point of agreement which is
would Americans choose to spend that
money in UK listen no that part is a
complete different discussion which is
look we got 32 and a half 32 000 give or
take uh veterans who are homeless right
now we can easily spend some of that
money to take care that these are guys
that put their lives on the line too
dying in this give us freedom verbal
veterans
we're okay so there's 32 of them that
are 32 000 of them that are home that
money can be spent elsewhere my my
biggest concern with Ukraine was how
suddenly that became our number one
priority in the world of what's going on
there and in Iran which you're supposed
like the feminist true feminists are
supposed to be more about concern about
Iran than Ukraine because Putin is not
targeting women Putin's targeting a
country the Iranian government is
targeting women and and women's rights
that's what Americans feminists are like
I'm all about taking care of women and
this is where the priorities don't make
sense they're not looking at what's
going on Iran not helping out the people
they're looking at over here you know
look the the one thing you said about
Rand Paul and yesterday even when we
talked to Curt Schilling about the fact
that people talk to these guys I feel
like nothing's getting done I love what
Rand Paul said at the end of the
discussion with uh Anthony fauci when
Anthony fauci said what he said Rand
Paul finished it he says uh history will
reveal uh whether you were right or
history will not favor you some
statement like that because history is
not going to favor him and the other
part in regards to voting I used to be
from the same mindset I want to make
sure the audience doesn't uh uh believe
that uh and I'm going to challenge it
you can challenge it back I think
voting is super necessary because if you
think nothing changes
rho v Wade and what just happened a few
months ago or last year whatever the
time was a few months ago 10 months ago
12 months ago is a byproduct of flipping
three seats under one term which has
never happened so voting has a lot of
power if you control Supreme Court 6-3
is the reason why Roe v Wade is no
longer a thing and States get to decide
how they want to treat abortion so I do
think voting has a lot of power I think
what is going to happen this midterms
why it matters say Democrats keep Senate
and Republicans keep house guess what
that means there's a gridlock so now if
it's a gridlock that actually favors the
people because nothing crazy out of
whack can pass so that's why a lot of
people are out there like yourself going
out there running around talking and
promoting again Herschel Walker and
whoever it is you're uh spending time
with because it actually matters today a
lot like we need nothing to happen for I
know people well you know we need
actually sometimes nothing happening is
better than things happening that are
bad I agree so sometimes you just kind
of like look don't do [ __ ] for two years
just be there you're our president for
the rest of your life Biden last name is
going to be remembered in U.S history
books it's not going to be obviously as
the best president ever good enough for
you no it's not believe me you have
someone that just must be there shut up
don't say anything don't screw up
anymore is that really what an American
is really asking from his president it's
this no way nobody's asking that but the
reality of it is he's the president and
you know he has the power to do a lot of
different things that you he's in for
four years you can talk whatever you
want with election you can talk whatever
you want with you know is he gonna wake
up one morning and pull off a Liz truss
well some people don't want that to
happen because I started the bit before
that is he gonna wake up one morning I
pray to God not oh you're going there
a lot of people don't want that because
you get
you actually
genuinely want him to die oh no I just
you know prefer he wasn't ever installed
as the president I just think it's a
real pity that the greatest country on
the face of planet Earth has a demented
old man who doesn't know where he is
being put in as president that seems do
you love Biden you want him as your
president no I'm not I'm not a Biden
lover but I'm not also not a trump
supporter so you know I'm a little
conflicted yeah so it's okay a real
quick question because I'm still kind of
who do you think uh I know it's still
early who do you think is going to run
and there's been a lot of people that
are like because I remember when um
who's who's the girl that flipped
recently
people like maybe if you know the census
gets it maybe there's been so much like
speculation what do you what do you
think and what do you what do you want
and what do you think is gonna happen I
want uh DeSantis with tools together
does this VP because she brings women
she'll bring Democrats she'll bring the
independence DeSantis will bring the
fire yes uh and will be a unified that's
what I want what I think will happen I
think Trump will put a run in it will be
a massively split issue and someone else
will prevail but I don't know who that
is got you when you say someone else you
mean on the left no so a different
candidate would make it through you're
saying that if Trump runs someone else
could beat him yes I believe that's true
who do you think could beat Trump well I
mean I'm the Foreigner aren't I they'll
be a bit of a screaming okay we've
already known you have no no problem
sticking your toes in other people's
business so Why Stop Now who do you
think is going to be Trump well I
believe DeSantis could beat Trump
absolutely I don't think Pence could I
don't think a young kid could yet he's
not well known enough I think Gavin
newsom's already picking out the kind of
drapes yeah
gavinism is definitely already picking
out other people's skin that he could
wear in his [ __ ] American Psycho he
walked when I don't know where Biden was
overseas somewhere Newsom took off his
jacket he's walking in the world he's
like oh yeah it's all set up he goes
with like a baby
[Music]
he is I didn't I didn't say anything
about policies anything you just said 80
of people in America you know 80 of
people you know you have to look at
themselves in the mirror right so people
don't vote based on policies people vote
on who looks good who sounds good who
can give a good one-liner who can give
some unfortunately that's how a lot of
people I totally agree with you yeah so
that's how people decide so that that
guy is extra to un the same way people
underestimated Trump who hate there's a
lot of people that hate Trump right and
they were underestimating him and people
people like yourself or Coulter or a lot
of people were going out there and
saying watch you're gonna eat your words
and you remember the day when they
announced that
School schools were closed and they were
bringing uh emotional animals like pet
the zebra in the back cause you're gonna
kill yourself and I had to go and says
I'm a comedian I went on stage in
Colorado and there was people like two
people in the back crying they were
bringing like sheep and dog and like
like emotional support animals to to
college universities because people
couldn't take it my favorite was when I
was watching CNN and they had to it was
on Election night when Trump had won
um which I'd like he did last time as
well but um yeah what he won and they
were trying to call Pennsylvania and it
was like they had some sort of facial
palsy because they just couldn't
they couldn't bring themselves yeah it
was so funny it was amazing so I said
one thing about Newsome not a California
guy but I've been pretty explicit about
how that cringy July 4th ad that he did
oh yeah uh he definitely looks the part
I'm not a big news and fam I actually
think he's annoying he definitely looks
the part good looking guy he's 6'3 by
the way Katie so that's you know not
short guys you'll probably like him well
however if you slept with Kimberly kill
foil you're out all right what happens
Donald Trump Jr's current girlfriend so
it's pretty pathetic however he does
look the part so if you're just looking
on Optics we all know that situation
with JFK versus uh Nixon back in the day
that if you're listening on radio you
were like well Nixon won this but if
you're watching on TV JFK was the guy
clearly so visual and marketability is a
big thing I also think on the flip side
these days Mrs kudos to Trump and a lot
of people that you know why they like
him is
he's at least authentic and Gavin Newsom
strikes me as the least authentic just
cringy politician out there like hi I'm
here to tell you that like it's just so
phony and it's so fake and it's so
[ __ ] corny and inauthentic and I
think if you're just judging a book by
its cover he kind of has that Vibe but
if you actually listen to what he's got
going on you're I don't think the
American people okay here's my other
questions um and I I respect Adam
because as much as he hates Trump he can
say something like I understand why I
like Trump
but when you can say stuff like you
understand you got the policies you got
the it was the person it was the image
it was the cover of the book so that's
why I understand what you're saying with
Newsome and I was gonna ask you who if
it's gonna be him and I thought Biden
says he's going to I don't think so
who's gonna run who's gonna be the
second one to go
so new to try to be the president of the
Democrats on the left on the left I have
my idea
you're not saying Michelle well I think
it's Michelle runs
and by the way I if if she if she is
asking friends and family like people
that and people that she values their
opinion
I I don't know if you're gonna have a
better life than the one you do if it's
purely for history go for it but you're
young like go enjoy 30 they can enjoy 30
years of an unbelievable life at the
young age that they have
parties life enjoy they can do that now
if it's about history
Hillary's not in Michelle's League I
think Michelle can hold her own I think
she can talk she can communicate she can
sell she can edify yeah but I think
there's I think there's quietly behind
closed doors I don't know why is there
no chance Pat that died I think this is
the season this the season for some you
know out of nowhere candidates to choose
to run that actually have a good chance
to become a nominee on the left uh I
don't think on the right I don't think
on the right I don't think anybody
stands a chance to be ahead of uh Trump
in the sand but on the left
I think Mark Cuban this is a good time I
think rock this is a good time although
he won't do it no I think uh Michelle
this is a fantastic time but I think
this is a season like even those
Hollywood stars and billionaires who
have a name for themselves this is a
very very good time I'll make a
prediction I think Cuban's gonna step
away from a apprentice and he's gonna go
spend time with his family
yeah I'm sorry a shark tank a shark tank
yeah and he's gonna come back and he's
gonna say after spending time my family
they've encouraged me to want to run
because they think America has a lot of
problems and they believe I can solve it
and I have a plan and all of a sudden
the next nine 12 months you're gonna
hear her make an announcement Mark Cuban
I think so and by the way I tell you I
tell you one thing yeah I I um
he's a capitalist but he's also he's a
he's a liberal he's a guy on the left
but he's not a socialist he is a
capitalist uh I think he has a chance to
actually be somebody on that side I
fully agree with you and I would vote
for Mark Cuban as far as that over a
Biden or a trump or anything divisive
like that Cuban over descentes
um I that I would generally want to see
them on the stage together and have an
unbiased General like gen like genuinely
curiosity curious mind to see what they
have to say I would actually appreciate
that let me let me put it through this
way
I didn't say I support I just said I
think they would run I'm not sitting
here telling you I'm supporting a uh a
Cuban running or not I'm not because he
still is a person that is gonna lean
more towards shutdown things like that
so just so you know like government laws
and all of that that is not something
that I'm I'm uh you know I think the
scientists will be like how Florida was
there in covet it's how America would be
if the census was president but just
think about that but if Cuban is
President and another covet happens it's
gonna happen what happened with uh
that's the point you're bringing up
Cuban because at the end of the day you
know that it's a realistic possibility
couldn't win you're not saying it's not
a far-fetched idea no no I'm not saying
I'm not saying I would support or not
I'm not saying I'm not asking support
you're saying it's it's something that's
feasible oh let me play let me put it to
this way he is a fool if he doesn't run
I'm telling you right now he's a fool if
he doesn't run if he's ever had which I
again gut feeling I don't know the guy
we don't have a relationship we've done
it you know one time I did an interview
with him and he was kind enough to uh
have me go to his office and American
Airlines we sat down we had a great
two-hour conversation brilliant guy
smart guy
if he's ever
found the perfect opening to go run
today's attention and here's my question
I want to ask all of you guys if
somebody like him does come in is he
backing out of any of these policies
that we've been seeing for these two
years is the Border gonna get okay is
anything really going to change or he's
going to just keep riding this train let
me let's not tell you what what I think
he would do he would actually talk to
the people like he would be on Twitter
saying he's going to give you his you
know what he believes needs to happen to
the Border he's not going to be hiding
okay but Cuban's not going to be hiding
you know how quickly he would respond to
an email I would send him like I
couldn't believe how quick he would
respond at two o'clock in the morning
one time him and I are emailing each
other back 30 seconds boom 30 seconds
back so he is like he's like this he's
on the ball yeah he's he's he's a guy
that will actually circulate amongst the
troops like he'll fly out and go meet
with people he'll sit down he'll do
those types of things uh him but I think
he's going to be more Pro shutdown I
think he's going to be more Pro you know
control I think is going to be more Pro
that of the mindset and I think that
doesn't sit well with people who like
what the scientists got you and some
others that's why that's why I moved
okay I moved here from four months ago
to come here work for patent I left
California and this is when you with the
scientists like you light up just like
me that's one of the main reasons that I
was like yeah I'll come here and that's
one of my things about Newsome is I get
that he's so marketable I get that he's
a brilliant speaker but half of
California or whatever is statistically
accurate leaving California they you
can't get a U-Haul truck to get you from
California to Florida anymore and you
can get paid to bring a U-Haul truck
back from Florida oh really yeah oh
that's amazing was it the first time in
100 years they've had a net uh yeah
what's the term net uh really net
vacancy whatever people leaving the
country well we have a guest here with
us so let's let's if we can uh turn our
attentions over to our guests if we
haven't already uh the zoom's been
switched over to them uh look I'm
excited about having a professor Matthew
Bon on for a couple different reasons
you know he practices a professor of the
practice of energy National Security and
foreign policy I mean once again uh give
a formal proper introduction he's an
American nuclear and energy policy
analyst currently a professor practice
at the Harvard Kennedy School at Harvard
University co-principal investigator of
the Belfort Center project on managing
the Adam and his father George Bund was
a leading figure in the field of Arms
Control who helped draft and negotiate
the nuclear non-proliferation Treaty of
1968 limiting the spread of nuclear
weapons worldwide uh Matthew bung it's
good to have you on
if you can hear us
let us know if you can hear us you look
like you're Frozen okay I can hear you
now I can hear you now
can you hear us or no
I can hear you let me know if you'd
rather I turn off my video that might uh
help a little bit you're actually fine
now whatever you're doing now it's fine
so it's it's good to have you on I you
know we got an article that came in and
the team was talking about it where uh
somebody asked you a question how like
these are Russian nuclear strike in
Ukraine and this was on October 2nd 2022
uh an NPR article your answer was we
have a 77 Year tradition some call it a
taboo of a non-use of nuclear weapons
Russia is threatening that
and uh you went on to say a few
different things we need to do
everything we can to maintain that
tradition of not using nuclear weapons
in combat so there's a lot of talks
about this whether you know it'll get
there or not a lot of people are
concerned uh you're hearing words being
thrown around of a World War III and
that's been trending on Twitter on a few
different days from your perspective of
somebody that's been in this your
father's been in this this has been your
topic of discussion for your entire life
How likely is it that we'll get there
that a Putin or someone will take the
first initiative of turning into a
nuclear war
so I don't think we're going to get to
uh a World War III where the United
States and Russia are lobbying nuclear
weapons at each other they are both
highly highly motivated not to do
something that could lead to the end of
both countries as functioning societies
what I'm more worried about is the
possibility that Russia might use a few
nuclear weapons in Ukraine uh itself the
United States uh has said that it would
respond in ways that were catastrophic
for Russia uh what I'm hearing is not a
nuclear response but rather
a political economic sanctions but also
conventional military
responses uh in that event but we would
have to expect that Russia would then
respond to that and the situation could
get quite dangerous nonetheless I think
it's very very unlikely we'd end up
ending up with anything remotely
resembling what people think of as World
War III got it so World War III to you
would be as if U.S got involved How
likely is it if a Pearl Harbor type of a
situation happens when Japan attacks us
and then a few years later that happened
under FDR and a few years later under
Truman he decides to Nuke them and it's
the only time this has happened two
times in a history of mankind where
we've actually nuked the place How
likely is it that this will be only
between Russia and Ukraine where Putin
to save face and how the world is
pitching him at the end of his career to
say this is not going to be happening he
nukes Ukraine and then there's a you
know agreement and it's over it versus a
world war three
so I think there are a number of
different ways it could play out uh very
few of which lead to World War III the
reality is uh Russia has thousands of
nuclear weapons uh the United States has
thousands of nuclear weapons each of
them are highly highly motivated not to
lob nuclear weapons at the other uh but
in Ukraine
uh Putin can't afford to lose
politically and he is losing at the
moment and he has threatened that he
would use all weapons at his disposal if
the ukrainians uh attacked areas that he
considers now part of Russia which the
ukrainians are highly motivated to do
now is that a bluff possibly I think
there's only maybe a 10 20 chance that
he would use a few nuclear weapons in
Ukraine he might use them
for coercion uh he might you know use a
few uh on a battlefield and then say
unless you agree to my terms I'm going
to start hitting Cities next uh so
that's what we have to put up with I
think the United States might get
involved in that circumstance not with
nuclear weapons but using conventional
strikes for example on the units that
carried out the nuclear strikes in
Ukraine how how uh how do you feel about
the way President Biden and our
Administration is handling the situation
with Russia specifically when it comes
down to you know how we're how we're
handling the relationship with Putin in
this case where the approach we're taken
the average person that doesn't follow
politics doesn't read Wall Street
Journal doesn't watch CNN or Fox News or
any of that stuff to them the average
person that's having watching football
on Sunday and the topic of Putin comes
up they they throw him in the category
of dictators and people in the past that
have done a lot of harm to a lot of
people but you know some people are
split and in saying look this guy is his
priorities Russia he never wanted to go
into World War III his main thing is the
history of Ukraine it was part of Russia
whoever negotiated before he wasn't a
part of it he's a true loyalist to what
USSR once was and he just wants his land
back and he wants everybody in the world
to stay out of it and NATO to stop you
know trying to recruit Ukraine back to
him why are you doing that I told you
that's the one thing I don't want you to
do so from your Optics how would you uh
how would you view how President Biden's
been handling it and what Putin's uh
motivation is behind this whole
situation that we're in right now
well I'm sorry to say part of your
question I would argue is reflecting the
success of Russian propaganda
Ukraine is an independent sovereign
country Russia has agreed that for
decades that Ukraine is an independent
sovereign country
um and under the United Nations Charter
countries are not allowed to just invade
their neighbors and seize chunks of
their land that was the fundamental
thing that the United Nations was
established to prevent and now we have a
founding member of the United Nations
with a veto on the security Council
waging aggressive war on its neighbor so
uh I do think overall I would give the
Biden Administration quite high ratings
they have uh used uh selective uh
release of U.S intelligence to
um warn the world of what Russia was
about to do and make it more difficult
for various Russian disinformation
campaigns to succeed because the world
was warned ahead of time that they were
going to happen they have
um sort of increased over time the
supplies to Ukraine and the kinds of
weapons we've been willing to offer
Ukraine and manage to avoid escalation
with Russia I think that we are going to
end up in a big debate between people
who say you know what Putin has done is
just evil we've got to push back we've
got to hold him accountable and people
who say whoa he's got thousands of new
nuclear weapons it's dangerous to be in
a situation where we have total hatred
between our countries it's not good for
us not good for the world uh and I think
there's going to be a tension between
those two
equally legitimate arguments uh over the
months to come last question here for
you unless if the panel here has a
question you know sometimes when this
conversation comes up and and you're
with friends and you got Republicans in
there you got Democrats in there you got
independence in there you got those who
don't give a [ __ ] in there right they're
just talking to each other and we all
have friends and family when we're by
ourselves talking uh you know uh some
will say well Pat say what you want but
Donald Trump when he was president there
was no war nobody thought about Isis you
know Palestine and Israel look at all
the stuff that he did and everybody was
afraid that was going to be world war
three under Trump but that never was a
trending topic on Twitter Etc et cetera
look what Biden is doing he's causing
world war three we can potentially go
there and look how much problems we're
having on the way we left Afghanistan
and by the way these are people some
people that are saying this are people
on the left that are saying this you
know Matt Zeller former CIA agent who
you know on Brian Williams talked about
hey the way we left Afghanistan that
shouldn't been the right way to leave
there's a lot of people that are not
happy about the way we've handled things
under a Biden Administration and a lot
that we're hoping that a Biden would
have been somebody that would have been
more peaceful less warless issues but it
seems like every other day you turn on
the news there is some kind of issues
going on whether it's Afghanistan
whether it's Iran whether it's Ukraine
whether it's Russia you know so what do
you say to the people that say under
Trump U.S was more at peace and less
fear of war was there and under Biden
it's been constant fear of potential War
what do you say to those people
uh well I respectfully disagree
um the reality is in 2017 as soon as
Trump came to power he launched a
massive crisis with North Korea that
almost led to war
um and it's absurd I would argue to
blame uh Biden for Putin's uh aggressive
decision to invade Ukraine
um Putin has been planning this for some
time including during the Trump
Administration uh so I think this is in
Putin's lap he wants to grab more land
that doesn't belong to him uh and the
world has appropriately stood up to that
aggression uh the United Nations General
Assembly just voted overwhelmingly to
condemn Russia's annexation of Ukrainian
land as illegal under international law
and the bud Administration has really
done a remarkable job in pulling the
NATO alliance together in a way Trump
utterly failed to do when Trump was
president
got it I have a question yeah um just so
we're all clear would you reveal where
you lean politically are you on the left
or in the right are you more of a
moderate are you just a believer in
common sense are you just an educator
what would you reveal
so uh I regard myself as a political
Centrist but it is true that I have uh
served in the past in Democratic
administrations and have largely uh it
offered my advice primarily on the
Democratic side okay so does that
um negate you from having having
credibility
uh I don't think so I think in our
country we need to have bipartisan
cooperation on not only National
Security but a wide variety of things if
we want to have sustainable public
policy over time unfortunately in the
world that we have today our country is
so polarized that it we keep reversing
course on policy after policy every time
you know one party or another takes
power just just a question before we go
to Katie hoppings I got one question for
you we had do you remember Mr uh uh
Peter pry
yep okay we we had them on a couple
times uh he rest in peace he just passed
it away about a month ago a month and a
half ago two months ago just I don't
know if you knew that or not he just
passed away yeah Peter did you know
Peter pry no but you just broke that
news oh yeah he just passed away two
months ago we had him on the podcast
twice twice in the span of a month and
then two months later he passed away
crazy uh uh
are you familiar with what his belief
system what the what what he believed uh
uh he viewed the nuclear threat that we
had did you and him speak regularly
because I I like what you just said
right now where Adam said do you lose
credibility to say what you're saying he
said no you know this is how America is
we get to sit there and debate and you
know agree and disagree and we get to
say well I agree with Professor Bunn I
agree with Peter pry how how different
of a world view did you have when it
comes down to nuclear threats from Peter
Pride the late Peter Pride
so everything somewhat different
um there are lots of different views and
in these uh areas Peter was uh
especially concerned I I would argue
um uh almost obsessively concerned about
one particular aspect of the nuclear
threat which is the possibility of uh a
hostile State uh detonating a nuclear
weapon up in space where it could create
a massive electromagnetic pulse that
would short out a lot of our electrical
systems over much of the United States
if it were a big enough bomb detonated
in the right place and Peter did a lot
of great work on uh elucidating that
threat but I would argue that's only one
of many nuclear threats that we face
got it thank you for that Katie
um so my question is about zelenski and
to what extent you think he's actually
an authentic or legitimate leader or
whether you think perhaps he is as I
believe
um an actor or a puppet in the sense
that he was an actor in rubbers and high
heels until relatively recently and now
we're supposed to believe he's Winston
Churchill so my question is about
zielinski and my second question is
given you say nuclear war is unlikely to
what extent do you think Americans
ordinary Americans Rust Belt Americans
really care about what's going on in
Ukraine to what extent do you think they
could find it on a map to what extent do
you think spending in excess of maybe a
billion or a trillion dollars in Ukraine
really matters to people who can't put
fuel in their car
okay
so uh two questions
um I would argue zielinski has uh proven
to the surprise of many to be a
remarkable wartime leader and
partly I think his
um media experience in the past has
allowed him to sort of dominate the
information space within Ukraine in a
very clever uh way that has unified the
ukrainians much more than they ever were
uh in the decades leading up to this war
so I think Ukraine is uh lucky that they
happen to have elected this leader it is
somewhat uh hilarious for Putin to be
describing the government of Ukraine as
a bunch of Nazis when uh they elected by
a voter of something like 70 percent a
Jewish president uh zielinski
I do think you're absolutely right that
a lot of Americans don't really care
much about what happens in Ukraine but I
think they should because
the principle all that countries aren't
allowed to just invade their neighbors
and grab chunks of their land if that
principle goes away uh we're in a very
very dangerous world and that was the
principle that we all agreed to after
World War II and we want to avoid
getting back into situations where we're
fighting Wars like World War II I think
I think blocking Russia in Ukraine is
actually quite important to U.S national
security in the end
um and that's going to be playing out
over the course of the months and of
course there is an enormous difference
between a billion which we've already
spent more than that and a trillion
which is a thousand times a billion
which is there's no Prospect of spending
remotely that say those numbers again
what do you think we actually spent
uh well we've spent uh
several billion I think over 10 billion
at this point in uh military and
economic assistance uh to Ukraine it's
going to be uh expensive When The War is
Over uh for some combination of Ukraine
and the International Community as a
whole to rebuild the place because the
amount of damage that's been done is
just horrifying like a rebuilding plan
we were having a friendly debate over
here how much money we actually spent or
sent to Ukraine uh some of us believe
it's in the billions of us believe it's
in the trillions it's do you have an
accurate number
it's not remotely close to the trillions
trillions is a really big number
but you just said it's 10 billion that
seems that seems very probably over 10
billion at this point it's around 70
billion it's around 70 billion give or
takes it's a lot of money that we've
spent I don't think that's correct but
well I don't none of us agree on
anything that's what we don't know right
but we all agree it's billions Katie
we're not it's not trillions but he says
10 he says 70. I said 10 10 billion and
70 billion is a lot closer together than
1.5 trillion professor Matthew Bond
first of all thank you so much for
taking the time to come in here giving
you a perspective very helpful thank you
so much have a wonderful day all right
thank you thank you
uh different perspective you know to see
where it's at and he is more optimistic
that nothing's going to be happening so
it's interesting to see what happens
there
um go ahead I'm gonna say something well
Pat Uh we're going back to uh what God
is weird to me what is that to him it's
only 10 billion into her it's in the
trillions and to me it's 70. I think
it's seven no no but no the the the
point the point the point is that
people who are in this world are
actually not tracking like what the
dollar amount is he thought it's only a
10 billion dollar number it's not 10
billion dollars and when he said 70 he's
like no there's no way yeah there's no
way I mean because people here like you
were saying people are just distracted
but then going back to like our you know
the way Biden's handling it and the
zelinski I think it was January back in
January when the whole thing was about
to happen with you know pooing and
dating I think uh Biden even said you
know what we're not going to get
involved if it's a minor incursion do
you remember when he was basically
inviting them to come in there to start
this whole the whole thing and I don't
know listen I know you might his father
knew about nukes or whatever I worked at
a nuclear missile base and I was hands
on in the military with people that were
miscelliers that was they were brilliant
about nukes they knew about it if a
nuclear weapon goes off in Ukraine from
Russia I don't care what anybody says
it's the beginning of an end it's a
nuclear weapon okay it's gonna change
the the people the land the atmosphere
the it's over running if and if if he
does something like that say what you
want we're not in a war with Russia but
we're we're giving billions of dollars
to one side that's like if two gangs are
fighting and I give you guns money
troops guess what say what you want
you're in the fight it's a bro we're
involved somewhere in this world if one
note goes off I'm telling you right now
other people that have them they're
gonna start to get edgy because if he's
saying what's gonna happen we're gonna
go and do more sanctions if he does a
nuke in Ukraine what the hell that's not
going to do anything and Pat you should
know this as a military guy if a bomb
goes off at that magnitude even if it's
a tactical everything changes it's over
it's over because then other people I'm
like oh [ __ ] they're really doing this
now we have to get you know we have to
get kind of involved because we have
them too and I mean it's if that goes
off it's going to be it's gonna be
really ugly I so agree with you America
is totally in that war 100 and like so
when the bridge blows it clear Sean
everyone says that's the Americans that
was Biden 100 Street whether it's real
not this yeah or the other yep or what
we can agree is that everybody thinks
that different thing and that's true in
America about lots of stuff everyone
thinks what they believe is fact yup
exactly yeah I mean I think we're all in
agreeance nobody wants a nuclear at all
okay so ugly it'll be very nobody wants
that but at the same time he didn't
bring up one major point you can't just
invade other countries now there's a
debate what the relationship is what
Ukraine and Russia in the past and all
the situations they have but
you end Doctrine you don't just invade
countries and you have other countries
on Russia's border I.E Finland for
example that just joined NATO that's
like look they're on our border can I
say we're not exactly uh in a good
situation that is a bit weird is that
when you did his CV and you read it the
second time or his bio he talks about
what his dad did yeah and I've never
done that my dad used to work on the
electricity board used to do electric
cables should I should I throw that in
my CV what does your dad used to do my
father was a little electrical engineer
oh me too yeah resume
that was hilarious because the countries
do invade other countries I mean we did
it in Iraq because we said that they had
we said they had weapons of mass
destruction we knew that they didn't we
still went now we're gonna invade and
take over there once we found out they
didn't have anything we're like we're
gonna change the name to the war to
enduring Freedom it's like come on bro
we that Invasion stuff is still
happening and I think like we kind of
were like that kind of go invade a
little bit but we're not going to get
involved unless it's really serious and
now look what's happening there's a
third of nuclear war so and like we said
earlier nobody cares do you think the
average person we walked outside right
now you said you know that we're we're
getting kind of close and this is going
down they're like why do I care why you
know most people don't care about
U.S politics period here internally yeah
you're right okay so now you're asking
them to care across the pond no across
Eastern Europe into Russia I'm supposed
to know who Voldemort valinski is I'm
supposed to know that he's shorter than
Putin I don't know what's going on
exactly I mean they should but they're
not so Adam I wonder if you would just
have the same feelings if Taiwan tried
to take over land in Japan or China or
like a hypothetical right or flip it
Ukraine marches into Russia do we stand
up and send Russia 80 billion or 50
billion dollars or 3.2 trillion dollars
yeah to stop the ukrainians yeah well
that's also a straw man argument Ukraine
is not trying to remember
exactly okay and I imagine China
invading Taiwan is realistic type
Taiwan invading China is unrealistic no
Russia invading Ukraine Israel is
happening Ukraine invading Russia
unrealism
so what if what if India invades China
India I'm asking about your principles
and if if it's the same across the board
yeah that would obviously we would send
80 billion dollars into the Chinese to
stop an Indian Invasion based on your
it's like India is asking if your
principles hold up this is the beautiful
thing that you're doing kind of like
Katie does you have some truth and some
conjecture and some falsehoods and
you're like weigh in on it I'm like well
there's some stuff you're saying that is
agreeable and sometimes it's not you're
trying to paint me in a corner as if I'm
supposed to say no one answer your
[ __ ] nobody puts out no I'm putting
nobody you're in the corner no we're
trying to get you out of the corner
emotionally can you pull up what I just
sent you it's important too oh my God so
this is uh he is so here's from New York
Times four ways to understand the 54
billion dollar Aid uh money in U.S
spending in Ukraine can you see the
whole thing or no will it allow you to
go up or not no but this is for May 20th
so yeah but what I'm saying to you is
that was five months ago right since
then we've given another give or take 20
billion yeah out of the 54 billion we
gave 9 billion was to help an
economically seven billion was food
assistance and Health Care 6 billion was
their military and security assistance 5
billion was grants and loans for
military supplies another one billion
was for migration and Refugee assistance
then some for Europe and Central Asia
assistance then foreign aid then 12 and
a half billion for weapons and other
supplies and eight billion for military
deployments and intelligence just in
that 54 billion and it's been another 20
billion or so since then an hour ago
Insider just broke lawmakers could rush
through another 50 billion in aid for
Ukraine so we're getting close to that
trillions
but but we're not very close we're not
close to the trillion but we're over 100
billion if we give them that's a lot of
money I agree but but that's like saying
I'm worth because it's like saying I'm
worth a billion dollars
how did you find that article
Google did you Google that on New York I
don't know oh you Googled it do we have
our friends or no I'm gonna poke my eyes
out yeah we'll have a momentary
she'd agree with this and you would too
if we took half I don't even want to say
the numbers that number that we just saw
gave you and we put that to our border
and fix our people America and the
Border bro
please like that's what we want like
it's enough of over there overseas
already help this bro so Vinnie should
we send any money any no hear me
to foreign
I don't we have military installations I
think we occupy a hundred if I could be
wrong I think might be 160 one something
like that we have bases everywhere we're
plotted everywhere to protect the world
with the world's police when it comes to
stuff like that nobody nobody really
helps us if we get into [ __ ] I think
until this is fixed and it's not 100
fixable as a veteran when I see veterans
on the street and they're dying when I
see homeless people when I see the real
problems that we have in Chicago and
look the Border all the stuff and puts
put that money invest there once we're
solid then I would say okay here's some
money here's some military assistance
but well until we're chilling I say no
so do you think we should send if it was
possible any money to help the people of
Iran I one if we're secure 100 yes I say
yeah 100 can I can I just say you think
we should I I'm saying when it's a
circumstance like that not people just
trying to start a war 100 100 what what
but the the point about NATO at your
point about America being the world's
policeman Germany and other countries
like mine were not putting as much
funding into NATO as a percentage of our
GDP as America was that was Trump's
point was that America is an unfairly
spending to protect the world when our
countries are not you know putting up
the dollars so that's all my point was
about kind of the NATO so anything
that's why Trump was kind of [ __ ] by
the way I think Trump missed a massive
marketing opportunity with the NATO
thing everything would build the wall
lock her up drain the swamp three words
three words three words three when it
came to Nato how did he not just say
make NATO pay oh he was just yeah it was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy weird argument
it was made no sense and if all he said
was make NATO pay a lot of people have
been like yeah okay three words
simplified I actually understand you I
think
I like that yeah he got he got people to
think about things that we've never
thought about come on Tyler you got do
we have him on or no oh sorry yeah
different conversations
I just needed to borrow Tyler's tech for
a second I'll keep you don't have a
phone in the states
no kidding because you said when you
were abandoned all that stuff especially
like you're which I'm I'm actually
you're just being a professional and
left it in the green room but I didn't
realize you guys were just like having
sex you were saying while we're waiting
for this person they cancel your bank
account yes when Trump tweeted me the
first time they took my PayPal when
Trump tweeted me the second time and
praised my outstanding journalism
uh they took my personal bank account
that I'd had since I was 14 years old
they just shut it down what was the
justification for that you don't have to
obviously can't you take that just
happened to Andrew take they shut down
you're gonna be shocked I'm not an
advocate of that whatsoever actually
sympathize with you on that that's
ridiculous take down your bank account
no no I I don't think you do advocate
for that so I don't think you're an
[ __ ]
actually there's a lot of people don't
disagree and they're not you're not
you're not
okay so we have our we have our friends
here our guests here from UK we
appreciate you guys for doing this
uh if we if we have them on uh I don't
see them I think they're about to join
you may want to approve them so Rob Rob
tested them they should be on here in
just a second okay sounds good so
recognize that guy though yeah I reckon
that's a good one
yeah
and it could be okay look at that look
at the eyebrows on him as well look at
those eyebrows
yeah you could braid my eyebrows they
are beautiful no they have been looked
after
look at his little twinkly eyes he's a
Syrian always remember that Syrian
Armenian don't forget so so if we got
them on I want to get right into it
because uh Tyler you said they have them
on or did we go to another topic uh
they should be jumping I think they
threw soup at the camera
Rob just said we had him I'm looking
into it see Tyler's so on it that was
not playing games give me 30 seconds
ever since you said the truth it's brain
just you're doing Monkey Wrench to tell
his brain how about this
if we are gonna get these going can we
tee up the story a little bit sir
it's not uh
I'll tell you guys here in a minute why
uh uh Tyler's saying he has it this is
very important on the way this is going
to be set up so so these ladies these
two girls Phoebe plumber and N Anna
Holland chose to protest in their own
way and they are part of the the just
oil activist and they threw soup all
over Van Gogh's iconic sunflower
painting and they glued themselves to
the wall and they're out of UK and this
was a trending topic all over the place
people were talking about it there we go
we have them on at that time and I
simply want to know what they're
protesting and I want to give them the
eyeball to share with us what they were
really protesting so if we have you on
uh uh uh If Phoebe is that you are you
and I'm sorry if I don't know the two
names
Anna how are you
very good first of all thank you for uh
agreeing to do this and being on we were
trying to do it I think last week
something happened uh sometime we had it
like three four days ago and then we
ended up doing it today so if you don't
mind take a quick moment what I just set
it up as yourself and your friend Phoebe
you guys are part of the just oil
activists you two chose to through uh
throw soup all over Van Gogh's iconic
sunflower painting and you glued
yourself to the wall can you can you
share with us what point you were trying
to make
yeah absolutely so in just up oil our
demands are that the government should
end all new fossil fuel licenses okay so
currently trying to push forward a
hundred new fossil fuel licenses which
will without a doubt kill us it's a
genocidal policy but they're trying to
push forward so in just stop oil we are
trying to prevent that from happening
we're trying to save not just ourselves
because our children are our families so
we decided to throw soup over Van Gogh's
painting there's a way not just to make
a statement about that and to get a
people finally talking about this
climate crisis but also to get people
talking about the cost of living crisis
which is fueled by the same people who
were pushing forward to this climate
crisis well listen whether you're
getting criticized for your approach or
not you got eyeballs and you got
attention so what you were trying to get
accomplished you got it and people uh
paid attention to what you're what
you're doing but now you said your
concern is that this could kill us this
could get pretty ugly Lee can you unpack
that a little bit for us on your
argument
yeah um you know so
we have created more emissions than the
entire Humanity up until that point
right now it is a matter of political
will in needing to change this rather
than the science not being there you
know this summer in the UK and the heat
wave we lost a third of our wheat crops
we're set to lose half of our potato
crops we're heading towards Mass famine
right now 33 million people are
displaced by floods in Pakistan 36
million people are facing severe famine
in East Africa right now the climate
crisis isn't a problem of the future
we're seeing the catastrophic effects of
it right now can I ask you what great
are you guys in high school or in
college
and we're both University students okay
yes I'm 20. listen please take that as a
compliment that you look young don't
don't take it by anything it's just you
look like you could be high school or
college So what at what point did the
climate crisis become a concern of yours
do you remember how old you were when
the climate crisis became a concern of
yours and what was the setting when you
sat there and said you know we better
start paying attention to this was it
early in high school was it in junior
high school or is this a recent thing
well I personally began paying a lot
more attention to not just the climate
crisis but the the political climate of
the world around me it's around age 14.
um when I've really started gaining an
understanding of all the news headlines
uh that were coming through and from
that point it just seemed that every
single year things got worse and worse
and scarier and scarier so in 2018 I
started finally trying to do something
about that so 2018 is when Extinction
Rebellion really became popular in the
UK and that's when I started getting
involved in marches in petitions in
writing letters to my Member of
Parliament but then I realized that none
of that made a difference no matter how
many marches I went on or how many
petitions I signed there was no actual
change happening you know a petition
could be signed by millions of people it
gets sent to Parliament of a House of
Commons they debate it throw it away and
are done by their lunch break you know
people those methods didn't work and it
was so frustrating so I joined Justin
Hoyle because we are a peaceful protest
group who use methods of Civil
Disobedience and non-violent direct
action to actually make change happen
and it really feels that since I've
started taking action with just stop oil
but finally what we're doing is making a
difference
yeah I think for me I am I became aware
of it it sounds a funny thing because I
think now we all are quite aware of the
climate crisis or to some extent but I
became aware of it probably around five
years ago and at first
I think I only connected with it
intellectually
you know you look at these science and
the facts and these predictions and it's
easy to connect with it intellectually
it's you can understand it but I'd ask
anyone listening to this right now to
connect with it emotionally
because for me that that's when I knew I
had to do something about it because as
a young person
I'm terrified about the future we're
facing are you really are you really
though are you really terrified are you
really uh uh concerned uh for your life
are you you know afraid of what's really
going to happen and if yes what do you
think really will happen like how what
how bad you think it's gonna get if your
concern is truly climate change that
this thing's Gonna Change how bad you
think things are going to be because AOC
said we we may be you know Season Two
exist in 12 years and I'm sure you guys
have seen that when she said that a
couple years ago and you know Greta you
know thundberg is going around talking
about how she called them uh called out
a lot of different political leaders
around the world for not doing anything
and she went out there and she got
noticed by a lot of different people are
you truly concerned about your future
when it comes down to climate change
yeah I really am last year sir David
King who was the uh former Chief
Scientific Advisor in the UK so what we
do in the next three to four years will
determine the future of humanity because
there's these tipping points that
scientists warn us of which when you
surpass them you've done irreversible
harm it doesn't matter the kind of
policy changes we make or the
sustainable changes we make once you
surpass those tipping points
irreversible harm has been done this was
a young person I'm terrified I'm going
to be denied the right to grow old I'm
terrified I'm going to live in constant
fear of climate disaster I'm terrified
that I won't have access to clean water
or food and we know that these fears are
real because right now millions in the
global South are living the realities of
these fears and they're the people that
have done the least to cause the climate
crisis
so what do you what do you think what do
you think about it and and I'm listen
I'm not in this space neither are you
guys this is something you're protesting
I have my own things I protest that's
important to me you know we all have
lived our lives and I have to we have to
respect everyone's concerns fears and
passions that they have in their lives
but what what do you think about rich uh
people who work for these large
insurance companies do you think they
like losing money
can you guys hear me or no I mean I
don't think anyone likes using money
that's why we have to use disruptive
tactics and you know in the UK right now
we are entering an awful cost of living
crisis right yeah earlier this year the
head of British Petroleum one of the
biggest oil companies in the UK so he
has more money than he knows what to do
with he has the audacity to say that
when our country is plunged into this
cost of living crisis where this winter
families are going to be forced to
choose between Heating and eating
parents are starving themselves so that
they can feed their children
I'm ahead of this massive oil company
says he has more money than he knows
what to do with yeah so you
let me give you an idea where I was
going with this question on what uh what
What's the one data that gets this
argument to be done with is a lot of
these actuaries in the insurance
industry their job is to underwrite the
billions of dollars that they're sitting
on to protect it like their job is to
manage risk that's what they get paid to
do they go to universities they come out
and they're supposed to study every
single thing and then this insurance
company is sitting on say 50 billion
dollars 20 billion dollars and you're
coming and saying I want to get XYZ
Insurance 30 years from now 20 years
from now insurance cost of insurance is
going lower life insurance different
kinds of insurance that's going lower
because people are thinking we're going
to live longer life expectancy has gone
higher in many different countries in
the world and the only reason actuaries
are charging life insurance to be so
cheap is because they're thinking we're
going to live to 100. like odds are
right now if Phoebe and I'm a little
concerned for you guys you guys are two
young healthy the attractive girls
you're probably going to live to a
hundred it's all going to be all right
for you to be afraid of the fact that
the end of the world is coming kind of
uh prevents you some of your best years
of your life to enjoy yourself now don't
get me wrong I love the fact that you
have a passion but what do you think
about these actuaries and these billion
dollar insurance companies that when
they do the math they sit there and say
you're probably going to live 200 years
old and if that's the case that means
maybe AOC and Greta are wrong what do
you think about these guys that went to
school and they do math all day just a
boring life and they try to protect the
billions of dollars of these insurance
companies
okay so this year we have the worst
droughts in 500 years that destroyed a
third of our wheat crop half of our
potato crop in the UK we uh this summer
we reached 40 degree heat which is
something that was not predicted to
happen by scientists until 2050. in
those just 48 Hours of 40 degree heat
1700 people died of heat exhaustion the
NHS ambulances were put on black alert
fire brigade had the busiest day since
the blitz you know we're not worried
about our future because we don't have a
future to be worried about this climate
crisis is happening right now we got so
lucky that this Summer that heat only
lasted 48 Hours next summer it's going
to last even longer next summer even
more people are going to die but no
let's look sooner than this summer okay
let's look at this winter in just a few
months two-thirds of the UK families are
going to be forced into fuel poverty you
know children are going to freeze to
death in their own homes because our
government are too lazy and too
incompetent and too downright abusive to
care about us we're not fighting for
some distant future we can't afford to
think that far ahead I don't care about
life insurance because I'm not going to
live long enough to cash it in I I
understand what you're saying yeah
I'm optimistic I just want to get to 25
that's my only goal right now you know
it's it's I understand what you're
saying and I I respect your passion and
it's obvious it's very sincere and
you're you're you're truly concerned
about this uh but I will tell you to me
a lot of time when you when you look at
these greedy people the good thing about
greedy people is you know if their life
revolves around money so let's see you
know the person you guys were talking
about earlier that he says I have so
much money I can't even count so let's
let's judge those greedy people the
benefit about greedy people is they're
they're it's a very honest relationship
what matters to them is protecting their
money and not risk losing their money
right they're not willing to risk all
the money that they've made and if
insurance companies are still given
insurance policies to people thinking
you're going to live another 80 years
that means that future is bright but you
know the the part of protesting for you
and for you to do what you do super
necessary go make your these people are
going to debate you they're going to
argue with you I remember when Al Gore
30 years ago said we're supposed to be
dead today you know and Al Gore's
documentary when he came up and he said
I don't know what it was 25 years ago or
30 years ago and a lot of people sat
there and said what happened your
argument just didn't have any
credibility but it got a lot of young
people to go out there and March and
protest and get excited about it so it's
a very effective message
say that again already
crisis I'm not saying that 10 years down
below we're going to die people are
dying now right now because the climate
crisis
right right well go ahead Katie So
Yesterday a lady that was involved in a
car crash actually linked to one of my
circle of friends she died because an
ambulance couldn't get through because
your protesters just stopped oil were
blocking the road and the ambulance
couldn't get through in time she
couldn't get the help she needed and she
died earlier you said that you are a
peaceful protesters my friend is dead
how do you answer that
we have a um we have a blue light policy
um which means whenever we have
roadblocks as soon as we um hear sirens
we see the blue lights people move out
of the way even when people are gluing
in the road there's always one lane that
is kept um clear so that people can move
out of the way and we have never had any
complaints from either ambulances fire
brigade or any other Emergency Services
the video footage exists and the lady
can't complain now because she's dead
let me ask you another question Phoebe
let me ask you what bills do you
currently pay who pays for your
accommodation at University
my student loan when have you ever paid
any bills in your lifetime
no so you don't know what it's like to
be a homeowner and not to be able to
afford your energy bills and then see
some stupid young people throwing soup
over a painting in a gallery that has
nothing to do with the fact they can't
afford to pay their bills you don't know
what it's like to pay a bill Phoebe do
you
no but I have empathy for those people
you know this the climate crisis is
fueled but the cost of living crisis is
fueled by the cost of oil crisis they
are both one crisis it's a crisis of
greed of our government and their
billionaire friends what do you
understand about an ordinary family who
can't afford to pay their fuel bills who
needs ordinary fuel to be delivered but
because of green taxation their bills
are now so expensive they can't afford
them and if we stop oil how much more
expensive do you think fuel is going to
be Phoebe or is it that you're just
spouting out words that you and your
friend think look good how is it related
to stopping oil to throw soup over a
painting in a gallery how is that
related how is it helping the poorest
people in my country
I understand that right now fossil fuels
are subsidized 32 times more than
Renewables even though Renewables are
nine times cheaper would you rather your
bills were 3500 pounds or 400 pounds I
would rather that you and your friends
stopped wreaking havoc in the city of
London I'd rather you stop throwing soup
over paintings stop putting orange paint
on the Windows of Harrods stop sitting
in roads so that my friend couldn't get
the treatment that she needed and I'd
rather you went out worked a bit maybe
you could do some litter picking on a
beach maybe you could do something that
was practical and helpful but I don't
think being obtrusive and obstructive
and lecturing Ordinary People when you
have no idea what it's like to try and
work and make ends meet in the UK you
talk about millions of people you talk
about people who are in poverty you have
no idea what that's like because you
live in the rarified atmosphere of a
University at some wokarati place and
you think what you're doing is changing
the planet I think what you're doing is
pissing people off and I think you could
allocate your energies more effectively
by going out and picking up picking up
litter on a beach
thank you can I just think
um I just want to empathize with you
Katie but it truly does break my heart
to hear about your friend
um it really does but I really want you
to understand that myself and Phoebe are
acting out of fear you know we are
terrified but you shouldn't be my
darling you shouldn't be you've been fed
a load of nonsense you're gonna live way
past 25 and I hope you live till 100 and
have a brilliant brilliant life young
people should not be in a place where
you're being intimidated by fear you
should be living the best life you can
jump jump and your wings will unfurl on
the way down you're limiting your whole
world
we should be living in life not standing
throwing soup in a gallery
because it's it has to be done with
fighting for our lives here the only way
we can make the change happen is if we
make systematic change I completely
empathize with you and I want you to
understand that this disruption that we
are causing will stop immediately as
soon as the government releases a
meaningful statement that they will stop
producing more fossil fuels it's as easy
as that but you I understand your anger
I really do I really understand your
frustration and I'm angry and frustrated
I really really am and but all this can
stop the minute the government's not
true because we need more fuel we need
more fuel supply one of the things about
supply and demand as you'll know is it
supplies restricted demand Remains the
Same prices go up it's basic economics
we don't have enough fuel supply
stopping oil is not going to help with
pricing you talk about Renewables
they're not there ready to take over
from oil well we currently have eight
years worth of oil in reserve so if we
stop new oil licenses now we would still
have eight years to make a just some
Fair transition to becoming a completely
renewable Society the biggest solar farm
in the UK was built in six weeks you
know we're in Ireland right now we could
be harnessing tidal power a current a
tidal power currently accounts for 10 of
our UK's energy I hear your stats I hear
your stats but do you see that you're
going to need to bring the general
population with you and people's opinion
with you and I don't believe you're
going to bring any people's opinion with
you when you're stood throwing soup and
artwork
well you know this isn't a popularity
contest the suffragettes were famously
hated Martin Luther King was voted the
most hated man in America when he was
alive and the thing is that right now we
know that these tactics of non-violent
civil resistance do work I'm sat here
today as a queer person and the reason
I'm able to vote the reason I'm able to
go to university the reason I'm able to
hopefully will someday will marry the
person I love is because of people who
have taken part in these acts of
non-violent civil resistance before me
well I'm I'm uh not to cut you guys off
I'm actually a food waste activist and
the fact that you guys do soup on the
painting really bother me because I'm
pretty sure there was hungry people
outside that would have loved to have
eaten it so because of that I'm gonna go
fill up my gas tank I have I have to
listen ladies I gotta tell everyone uh
did you want to see yeah just one quick
question for you um I applaud what you
guys are doing
two tenses
um kudos to you guys for for at least
being very passionate about something 20
years old I you know if you're both 20 I
was not half as passionate about
anything as you guys are so respect on
that but there is a famous quote out
there that says when you're young and if
you're not liberal you have no heart but
if you're as you get older if you're not
a conservative you have no brain so you
guys are going to figure that out along
the way we all are so respect you here
are my two questions legitimately what
pronouns do you identify with that's
number one number two if there's a
hundred of your friends in a room and
you talk about your top
issues that you care about what's number
one two and three meaning climate LGBT
rights the economy health care so
pronouns and your issues if you would
uh so I used they she he pronouns
whatever you're in the mood for
um and for me I think the climate crisis
and also the cost of living crisis are
uniquely unifying because this will
affect everyone
and your friend
I also go by Bay Bank for announce I
also don't see how that comes into this
argument because the this is what we're
facing is climate crisis goes beyond
anything to do with gender sexuality
but I completely agree with Phoebe the
main concern my friends and I talk about
is the climate crisis and the cost of
living crisis my University had to open
a food bank for its students this week
that's how dire things are students who
are already getting a loan by the
government to pay for things like this
can't even afford to buy food using that
loan yeah it's all the energy bills
because of the climate crisis Phoebe our
biggest
against meat and just feeding myself
Phoebe Anna if you had an outcome that
you wanted to get with what you did you
got it you guys were able to get the
attentions of others to present your
argument and I I applaud you for your
emotional control because you were
pushed uh and folks came at you here and
you were able to give your argument now
whether the audience agrees or not it is
what it is whether anybody sits there
and agrees with you or not it is what it
is I plot you guys to be respectful in
return and I value that so thank you so
much for coming on and sharing your
views uh we appreciate you guys have a
wonderful day guys the future looks very
bright by the way just so you know I
believe the future looks very bright
take care guys bye-bye bye-bye Take Care
thank you thank you Phoebe thank you
Anna Take Care by the way honestly
respect you know say what you want man I
I don't know if I'm 18 years old I'm 20
years old I'm not responding though
but you know what it is though this is
the one thing I thought about the the
whole time I'm listening to this is what
I thought about at a 10 year old a nine
year old a six-year-old and then 17
month old
the power of universities what they do
to people to get you to be afraid
thinking you're about to die in the next
five years the the influence professors
have today the influence teachers have
today what you just saw is two people
back to back that we had on like three
people
the the second one is the byproduct of
the first one the second one is a
byproduct of the first one the influence
the first one has over the second one
and then people come out with degrees
we're sitting there supposed to think
you know and you don't understand what's
going on you don't understand what's
going on with us and we have to take it
wow you have to sit there and listen to
it so anyway it's fascinating I thought
um
you know so one hand
um I guess to your point slightly that
they I you know I I'm not going to make
it to 25 at this rate like my aim is 25
and she I'm not mocking she believes
that yeah but my pronouns are they
so wait a minute you had time to work I
didn't understand their pronouns is what
they were they them and him
nobody gets it that's the whole point I
don't know I don't they're not one
person yeah so they want to be so Phoebe
can only be identified as they if you
speak of Phoebe you say they they are
coming over they came on the show then
yeah her by herself they has a sandwich
oh so when I said ladies that's that's
not enough
guys you messed up three times
that's why I asked that question
which I really loved girls are you are
you like 10 years old so you said High
School
ERS
I'm thinking from a business standpoint
you know from a business standpoint they
could have gone a hundred dollars if a
hundred thousand dollars if they would
have called Campbell Soup saying we want
sponsorship right and this is this is
Campbell's Soup
five seconds you just gotta go like this
and then the glues
this protest is brought to you by
Campbell Soup Elmer's glue and look I
can't take my hand off the goddamn so
anyways
yes I was gonna say Katie I know we're
about to wrap up I don't want to be too
presumptuous but I'm extending another
invite for you to come back anytime
you'd like that's so sweet I love
sweetheart I love her hour and 30
minutes ago yeah I'm gonna be in the
middle of this yeah
maybe it was the U.S British thing that
we had and it caused fireworks and I
when I see British people first of all I
think let me give you let me give you
one perspective why you should love her
you know why let me tell you tell me why
if she thinks if she thinks
60 billion dollars or three trillion
dollars she could think a lot of numbers
are bigger yeah
respect for men out I'm allegedly a
million come back I'm gonna come back
with the numbers on you Craig real quick
yeah
just so you know the future looks bright
some crazy [ __ ] is going on it's gonna
be wild you don't know what's gonna
happen in Russia Ukraine we feel bad for
the folks that are going through the
families that have nothing to do with it
the ones in Iran the ones in Taiwan all
these families they just want peace but
they're in the middle of a government
going at it with other people I'm
convinced the future looks bright as
messy as it is everything's gonna come
down to leaders rising up and making
things happen so appreciate you guys for
being with us Katie thanks for coming
out this was fantastic as usual have a
great weekend are we on back uh uh we're
back Tuesday with the one and only Chet
hangers next week oh fantastic and I'm
doing a show at one o'clock today with
preach from and preach right here in
this oh cool so we gotta flip this
around okay we gotta go guys have a
great weekend take care bye bye bye bye
bye